okay everyone good morning uh welcome to
ndc oslo in oslo
so um this talk is called the power of
composition
and uh my name is scott veloshan and i
have a website
f sharp for fun and profit.com
um as you can guess that's mostly about
f sharp
uh i'll be using c sharp and f sharp
codes
mostly f sharp code examples but these
concepts
work uh for almost any programming
language
um for example there's a lot of people
doing this kind of thing in javascript
uh php ruby uh
python and so on uh
right so i am going to talk about a
couple of things first i'm going to talk
about the
philosophy of composition and
um there's a there's a certain way of
thinking about doing things and
i just want to kind of really hammer
that home because what i'm going to be
talking about all
the time here i'm going to talk about
functional programming some
ideas about functional programming which
is functions
and how to compose them and types and
how to compose them
so i'm assuming that we're using a
statically typed
functional programming language if
you're using um a non
dynamic language like javascript a lot
of this doesn't apply in the same way
and then i will actually have some
examples of how to do composition
so we'll start with some roman numerals
we'll do a functional version of
fizzbuzz
uh and then we will talk about monads
and then i'll show you how you can build
a web service using
just composition with no classes
uh no mutability nothing like that so
yeah everyone's gonna be scared about
the monad bits
and hopefully it won't be so scary when
we get there
so let's start with philosophy
so there's some important things that
you need to have before you can
understand how composition works this is
critical first of all you have to have
been a child at some point
a very important you have to have played
with lego
and it also helps if you have ever
played with a toy train set
so these are kind of the prerequisites
if you haven't done these things then i
i highly suggest you go and play with
some lego and
you play with some toy trains and in
fact you don't actually have to have
been an adult
um there's a child though quite a few
adults who still play with lego
if you google adult friends and lego you
will see a lot of interesting things
um so hopefully all of you have met the
requirements
for understanding composition and so if
you have then the rest of this will be
very easy
so let's start with the lego philosophy
so lego actually has a philosophy which
is why it's such a great
thing to use because all the pieces are
designed
to be connected now as i talk about lego
every time i talk about lego you think
about programming okay
so i'm going to make an analogy very
soon so all the pieces are designed
to be connected all the pieces are
reusable
and if you connect any two pieces
together you get another piece
that can be connected okay so let's go
into this
all the lego pieces have little bumps on
them right
and when they design a new lego piece
they always put a bump on it
because they know that this piece is
going to be reused with other lego
pieces so they when you when you design
a lego piece you think about how it's
going to be reused
and when we design our programs we want
to think about our components of our
programs we want to think about how they
can be used
and the other thing of course is that
lego can be taken apart and
put built one thing and then use the
same pieces to build something else
and this works because the lego pieces
are self-contained they do not have any
strings attached literally which means
you don't have to like disentangle them
before we can reuse them
now if they had like strings attached or
electrical cables or something
they would be really hard to reuse them
um but they are each piece is completely
independent
so from a programming point of view we
want to have
pieces of our program which are
completely independent that can be
reused
and uh if you ever try think about like
a method refactoring we have to pull out
a method
because it's tangled up with other code
methods don't are not reasonable this
way
right um here is how you build
big things out of small things using
lego you connect two pieces together and
you get another piece
and once you've put two things together
you don't have to stop you can keep
adding
and adding and adding and you never have
to stop because no matter what you do
there's always some more bumps that you
can add something to
and that's a really important part you
never like hit a brick wall
and you have to use an adapter pattern
or a bridge pattern or something
yeah you just lego is always connectable
so making big things from small things
this is what you get
that's awesome and this is the power of
composition
that's the buzzword i'm going to say the
power of composition over and over
it's a great it's a great tool all right
now let's look at uh
wooden railways uh hopefully everyone
has played with one of these
they're also a lot of fun again all the
pieces are designed to be connected
all the pieces are usable if you connect
two pieces together
you get another piece that can be
connected
so every single piece is designed to be
connected they all have the little
uh bumps sticking out all the holes in
them i don't know what you call them
um again they're reusable you can take
them apart and
stick them back together again and they
are designed to be reusable from the
very beginning and
if you do connect two pieces you kind of
get another piece it's not exactly a
piece but
you get another segment of track that
can be connected
to other segments of track and again you
can keep adding and adding there's
nothing that stops you
making a really really long piece of
track you don't run into any kind of
artificial barriers
so making big things from small things
boom
this is a big railway model so that's
the power of composition
all right so now i'm going to say that
if you understand
lego and you understand toy railways you
know everything you need to know about
composition because what it is is just
taking these same principles and
applying them
to programming so that's what we're
going to be talking about in the rest of
talk
so let's talk about functional
programming now
what are the concepts of functional
programming and how do they relate to
this idea of
composition so i'm going to talk about
four ideas
first of all that functions are things
right so i'm going to use a little
railway analogy for talking about
functions
and the way we build bigger functions is
using composition we're going to use the
lego approach
to build bigger functions now
if you're coming from an object-oriented
world with static typing like c-sharp or
java
it's very important to know that types
are not classes
they're more like sets and i will have a
little section
explaining that bit too and
in a functional programming language you
build bigger types
from smaller types using composition
just like you do with lego
so again we're using this compositional
approach to build big things from small
things
right so let's start with functions as
things
so this is uh something that people
sometimes have a hard hard time with but
it's actually pretty straightforward a
function is just a thing i'm going to
use the railway analogy
so here's a little bit of railway track
and imagine there's a tunnel
on the railway track i call this the
tunnel of transformation
um we have in this case we have an apple
going into the tunnel
and it goes out as a banana so this is a
function
that turns apples into bananas um
yeah what can i say now the thing about
a
a function is it's a standalone thing
it's not attached to a class
so just like a little bit of railway
track i can move it around and put it
anywhere i need it
and so a standalone thing is another
word for a reusable thing
because there's no strings attached i
can in every all
everything it needs is provided on the
input so this it's not kind of tied into
a dependency on a class
or something else no global variables
you know nothing like that
so no strings attached is very good now
the other thing
about a function being a thing is
it can be used as inputs and outputs to
other functions
so just like a string or an int is a
thing
that you can pass around a function is a
thing that you can pass around
so a function can be used as a parameter
so let's look at some examples here is a
a function with a normal input like an
essay it has a string as an input
but the output of this function is
another function it's just a thing
um here is a function with a normal
output
but the input is a function here is a
function with a normal input and a
normal output
but there's another parameter which is
another function which kind of controls
how the main function
works uh so you could call this the
strategy pattern
a functional plugin the functional
version of that
and so here's all the different things
you can do with functions uh one
particular one you can do is you can
have a
a function which has a function as an
input and a function as an output
um which i'm going to call a function
transformer
so it's all the whole job of this thing
is to transform
functions from one kind of function into
another kind of function that's a really
really important component of functional
programming and we will see one of these
uh later on in the talk so
that's the foundations of functional
programming that's it that's all you
need to know
and uh you can see i mean it's it's
that's the basics but you can get you
can
get very complicated you can have a
function that returns another function
that has a factory for other functions
and so on and so forth
so yeah it gets complicated but the
basic ideas
are very straightforward right now
we've got our functions how do we
compose them together
to make bigger functions well
um let's take two of our functions we
have an apple to banana function and a
banana to cherry function
how can we connect them together well
what i like about the railway analogy is
it's really obvious
you just take the output of the first
one and feed it into
the input of the second one and when you
do that
you connect them together and you make a
new function
and this function turns apples into
cherries
and what's interesting is that you
cannot tell that it was built from
smaller functions
um you know the banana has disappeared
for example
nobody cares about the banana now this
is a new standalone function which you
can use
and you can hand around to people and um
you can use this as a component an even
bigger
function so you could you know have
another function which takes cherries as
input and and
combine it with that one so you can just
build
compose functions just by connecting the
inputs to the outputs and that's all the
composition means
for functions so let me show you how
this works in
c sharp and f sharp and
here is some c sharp functions written
as lambdas
add one times two and square
now if i was going to call these
functions
uh in a kind of multiple different ways
i normally have to do this kind of
nesting thing so if i want to say
add 1 to 5 and then multiply it by 2 and
then take the square
you have to kind of start in the middle
and add all these parentheses
around the outside and as they get
deeper and deeper it kind of gets kind
of complicated
and it can get kind of confusing so let
me show you a different approach
that is i think less confusing and this
is the piping approach
and this is based on the idea if you've
ever done unix command line piping you
know exactly how it works
you take you basically take the input
you feed it into the function and you
take the output
and then you take that and you feed into
the next function
and then you take the output of that and
you feed it to the next function
and you take the output of that and you
feed it into a next function and so on
so you have a pipeline
where the data kind of moves through the
pipeline
so hopefully this is pretty
straightforward um and i think this is
actually a lot easier to understand
let's let's look at some codes so in
f-sharp
this is the standard way of doing things
in f sharp which is the pipeline
approach
and so this is five piped into add one
five piped into add one take the output
feed it into times two
take the output of times two and feed it
into square and this is how you'd write
this kind of chain of functions
in f sharp and and that little vertical
bar with an angle bracket is the pipe
symbol in f sharp
uh the vertical bar on its own which is
what unix uses
uh means something else so it's a
slightly different uh pipe symbol but
that's what it is
and i think a lot of other languages are
using this too
alexa uses it i'm pretty sure that
javascript is going to get it too
it's a great uh great way of doing this
kind of thing
so you can do this even in c-sharp or
java um it's not as idiomatic
but you can basically write an extension
method um
that does this so if you do want to do
this kind of thing in c sharp you can
i think most other c programmers
wouldn't really know what you're doing
but it is totally doable it's nothing
this is not a language specific
idea you can do this in any programming
language
right now we know how to connect two
functions together
how do we build big things some small
things right
so i'll just make up a night example of
how you can
start with a very small thing and build
a very big thing and we will actually
see an example of this
at the very end of the talk when i build
a web service
so we'll start with a low level
operation like
say uppercasing a string as an input and
an output so this is a function
okay now we have a bunch of these low
level operations
and let's say we want to make a service
that
validates an address so the input is an
address and the output is some sort of
result
and inside this service you combine
these low-level operations to do
something useful
and i like to use the word service uh
because it's just like a microservice
without the micro in front and i'm over
40 and that's what i'm used to
so there you go um services
okay so we have all the different things
and we combine them into a complete use
case a complete scenario complete story
whatever you want to call it uh let's
say you want to update your customer
data in the database
um the input comes in and the output
goes out now this is not
this is an input output model this is
not a request response model
right so in an object oriented thing
that you'd have a request and a response
back
in a functional model it's an input
output and
so you can change this because input
output you can change this
this is just another function you can
chain it with other functions
right so let's say we have all these
different use cases or stories and we
want to combine them into a web
application
now if you think about it a web
application is actually a big
function the input is a http
request and the output is an http
response so it's actually a function
with an input and output
so let's model this as a function and
then inside this function
we basically have to choose which one of
these stories or use cases to run
so there's a controller or a router or a
dispatcher
or whatever you want to call it but
there's some way of deciding which one
of these things to run
based on what the request was but it's
still a function
okay we're using the same technique at
all scales
so if we take a if we look at the kind
of the insides of a complete
web function um yeah there's branching
going on you know it's not it's
obviously gets kind of complicated but
the interesting thing to note is that
the data only flows in one direction
something comes in and it flows through
and it comes out the other side
there's no loops there's no kind of
tangled mess
of interrelationships in functional
programming it's very very common to
have this one directional
data flow that makes it a lot easier to
understand what's going on uh it makes
it a lot easier to debug
um and it makes it a lot easier to test
because you can pull out these little
pieces each one of these functions is
testable
in their own right which is very nice
okay so that's the power composition the
functions the power composition
the wire race the power composition for
lego it's the same idea we're using
exactly the same idea for all
three ways of building things so right
now let's move on to
types so if you've got a statically
typed language this is a bit you might
be interested in
um so types are not classes as i said
they're more like sets
so what do i mean by that what do i mean
by a type
well if you think about a function a
function
has a set of valid inputs and a set of
valid outputs
all the things you can pass in and all
the things that are invalid to come out
so just think of the set of inputs right
that is the a type a type is just a name
for a set of things so if we have
all the possible integers being the
valid set of inputs we call that type
integer we give it a name integer now we
could also have the set of all even
numbers
we could call that type even number we
could have the set of all prime numbers
we can call that type prime number
so there's nothing special about
integers um it's just a set of things we
could have all the set of numbers which
except zero so non-zero integers or
something now there's no behavior
right there's no behavior with these
integers it's literally just a set of
things
we can have a set of strings again
there's no behavior it's just literally
just a set of strings
we could have all the set of strings
that start with the letter a
you know we could have strings which are
five characters long
it's just a set of things um it's a set
of people
right they don't have to be programming
jargon they can be anything
instead of people uh here's the set of
little flutes
and because it's a set of things you can
have anything in the set
in particular you can have a set of
functions so
this is an example of the set of all
functions
that turn fruits into fruits
and we write this as the fruit to fruits
type
that's the name of the type fruit arrow
fruit
and we will see this also later on
okay so these got these types now the
thing about
types in a static in a functional
programming language is they can be
composed
just like the just like the railway and
the lego
and this is due to something called an
algebraic type system
and algebraic is a bit of a jargon word
so i'm going to call it a composable
type system because that's exactly how
we use it a composable type system
and this is only possible because in a
functional programming language or in
this kind of type system
the behavior is separate from the data
right because it's just
sets of things you can do set
intersection and
you set union and you can do cartesian
product of sets
all these kinds of things you can do
with sets and that's how you can build
bigger sets and smaller sets
and that's only possible again because
there's no behavior there it would be
much harder if you had if the behavior
was
tangled up with the data so
let's look at how you compose things in
a
functional in an algebraic type system a
composable type system
well there's two different ways you can
compose them with and and you can
compose them with
or and this is i'm going to use the
english words and and all because this
is
how i think of them so let's look at and
what i mean by composing with and
let's say that i want to uh make a fruit
salad i want to model a fruit salad
well in english i would say an apple and
a banana and a cherry
i use the word and and in a programming
language like c sharp for example
i say okay here's the different kinds of
apples and bananas and cherries they're
enums
but then i want to compose them together
and i would say
it's an apple and a banana and a cherry
so that's how you do it in c
sharp and what it is it's just a struct
or a record
or a class or whatever a dto however you
want to call it it's something with
three fields
and all three fields are required right
so it's an apple
and a banana and a cherry so this is
something that everybody's had
experience with every programming
language supports something like this
and in f sharp it's very very similar we
have something which is called a record
and it has three fields
notice that the types come afterwards
rather than before like in c sharp
so this kind of looks a bit like jason
so we'll see some of these in a minute
now the other way of composing things
is to use or so in english i might say
i have a snack or a banana or
a cherry now you can't really do this in
c shop so let me show you the f sharp
way of doing this
um i say an apple or a banana or a
cherry and i'm using a vertical bar
to use to mean or and
uh in f sharp i like to call these
choice types
because we're making modeling a choice
between different things it can only be
one of these things it can't be all
three you have to pick one
that that is it's either an apple or a
banana it's not
you know all of them at once it's not a
field so uh
these are technically called
discriminated unions or
some types sum um
i like to call them choice types because
that's how i think of them
so you can think of it as almost like an
enum in c sharp with a
extra information right now what do we
do
with these types when we want to uh
compose them
so here's a little exercise for you
imagine that you want to
implement a payment method and you take
three different kinds of payments
cash paypal and credit card and for cash
you don't need any extra information
for paypal you need an email address for
credit cards
uh you need a card type and a card you
need some stuff so you've got three
different choices how would you
implement this
well if you're doing object oriented
design you would probably
start off with some sort of base class
abstract based class or an interface or
something
and you'd have three different
implementations of that interface or
that uh
abstract base loss and that's this kind
of typical object-oriented way of doing
things
now let me show you a completely
different way which is the compositional
way
where you build things up from smaller
things just like with the lego
so what we're going to do is we're going
to start with the small things
and in domain driven design i never use
words like string or
i want to use the same words that the
domain uses so i'm going to use the word
email address and the word card number
so i've got some aliases for primitive
types
and then i can make a choice a card type
is a visa or mastercard
and a credit card information is a car
type and
a card number so notice i'm using the
word or and and
so a choice type using or and a record
type using and
and then i can build my payment method
so it's cash
or paypal or card
so it's a choice type with three
different choices
and in the paypal case it's got some
email it needs an email in the credit
card case
it needs the credit card information and
in the cash case there's no other
information
but i don't have to stop because i can
keep adding and adding this is the thing
about composition i can then use this
in another class in another type rather
so i can make some more
helper things like a payment amount is a
decimal and a currency
is a euro or a dollar
or a ruble um and and then i can build a
bigger thing
which is an amount and a currency and a
method
i'm now using that payment method that i
defined up above
and i can keep going and going and
building bigger and bigger
types from the smaller types so this is
exactly like the lego
analogy but now we're building it we're
using it to build types
so this is buildings bigger types and
smaller types
this is the power of composition applied
to a type system
so very good power composition
right now uh these composable types
actually really
amazing um first of all they can be used
as
executable documentation and and i have
a big
uh this is one of my favorite things so
if i show you a whole bunch of types
this is a whole bunch of different types
here
can you guess what i'm programming
and i think you probably can it's
something to do with the card game
and what's nice is even if you don't
even understand f sharp you have a good
idea of what's going on because all the
types
are very self-documenting and they're
always
they're all in the same place they're
not scattered over
20 different files so there's one one
single file i can look at
i get a good idea about what's going on
in the domain
and you know mostly people think about
types as
data but you can also model
verbs actions so for example here we
have some actions
um some activities and we can say to
pick up a card
uh the input is this and the output is
this to deal a card
the input is a deck and the output is a
new deck and a new card
um you can model not just nouns but
verbs as well and that's very very
important
so what's very cool about this is we
have the entire domain on one screen
and uh you know rather this is like nine
types and rather having nine different
files they're all
next to each other on one page so i
think this is a great way of doing
documentation
and if you're a new person if you're a
new member of the team and you come
aboard
and and someone says you know uh find
all the payment methods and fix them up
or something
you know it's really obvious what the
payment methods are i mean if
again i don't have to go to four
different files they're literally all
here i don't have to go to the
documentation
i don't have to ask anybody i can just
look at the code and it tells me what's
going on
so i think this is a fantastic idea um
this is a massive topic i have a whole
talk on this i have a whole blog post on
this and i have a whole book on this
so if you're interested check out my
book um
uh yeah people seem to like it
right now let's look at some real
examples
um let's start off with doing a very
simple piping example
used for roman numerals okay
so here's some roman numerals how do i
convert an arabic integer
into roman numerals so i mean five
becomes v and twelve becomes x one one
and
hundred and seven becomes c v one uh c v
one one
i i i should say so that's the kind of
thing this is a very
standard exercise now we're going to do
it using the piping approach
now in order for that to work um i'm
going to show you
a slightly different approach than you
might be used to which is
going into the fundamentals of how roman
numerals came to be
which is this tally system right you
basically make marks
and when you've got five four marks then
you put a slash through it
and then you know you just make marks on
a on a
tablet or how on a wall or however you
do it um
i think this is how they evolved and so
we're going to do exactly the same
approach
for our design we're going to start off
with n copies of an i so if you have
you know 37 we'll have 37 little
scratches
and then every time we see five
scratches we'll put a v
there and then every time we see two v's
we'll put an x
and every time you see two five x's
we'll use an l and so on and so on
so this is the design we're going to use
for our roman numeral
algorithm so how does this convert into
a piping model well it's really easy
we start off by replicating the number
and then we do a replacement
we replace the five eyes with the v and
that gives out another string
then we place two v's with next that
changes another string
uh we replace the five x's with l
and that is another string so we're just
passing a string through each section of
the pipeline
so that's the the design the piping
model
let's actually look at the code so we'll
start with the c sharp code
so what i'm going to do in the c sharp
code is to find a little helper
function for each step and these are
going to be nested
internal functions inside the main
method okay so we start now once we've
got our helper functions
we can say you know make the string
uh however many times and then pipe it
into the first function
pipe it into the second function pipe
into the third function and so on and so
forth
so we have the helper functions and we
use them
in in the piping logic this is a little
bit ugly and i'm going to make a better
version of this
very shortly we can do the exactly the
same thing in f sharp
we have these little helper functions
and we define them underneath the main
one and then we define them
uh that we use these helper functions in
the main pipeline
so that's the concept of
um doing a pipe so
that's pretty straightforward um but
here's the problem
okay it's not always this easy
like most things it's like yeah it's
easy if it all works out but what
happens it doesn't work out
so we so far we've had these functions
with one output
and one input and when we want to
compose them together
they just connect up very easily that's
all good
but that's not always the
situation we have sometimes we have a
function
with two inputs and we have another
function with one output
and we want to try and connect them
together and how does that even work
so this is a problem how do we compose
these things
so now let's look at um
currying we're going to take the same
roman noodles thing and we'll just tweak
it
to use a different technique so we use
this replace function a lot
and this replace function actually has
three inputs um
the input the original the proper input
string and then the two values that
to find and replace and the output is
another string
so let's look at if we want to just use
these in line without having these
helper functions
um could we do that well no we couldn't
because these replace functions cannot
be chained together
because it has three inputs and
that doesn't work so can we fix this
problem
and you know it's these composition
patterns
are really great when functions have one
input and one output
but they don't work when functions have
don't don't fit that pattern
so you might think well this is really
bad that's a shame but there's actually
good news
the good news is that every function can
be turned into these one parameter
functions
so there's a trick where you can make
every function into one parameter
function
and then the composition works great and
that's what we're going to do now we're
going to do this trick
and this trick is called currying named
after haskell curry
even though he was not the person who
invented it and um
nothing to do with indian food is to do
with a person
so here we have an uncarried function
which is an uncurrent function is a
function which has multiple inputs
right and what we want to do is
transform it
into a function that has one input
well how can we do that what we do
is we make a function with one input
and what it spits out at the other end
is not the original thing but another
function
so we have the first function takes one
input
and it returns a lambda or another you
know an anonymous function
and that other function has one input
which this case is b
and then that it returns to c and you
can keep doing this
as many times if it has three parameters
you can have the second one return
another intermediate function
and so on so forth so this is a bit of a
strange thing to get your head around
um but it works really really well for
doing the kind of thing
uh that we want to do with multiple
inputs
so curried functions are basically a
function where every single
every part of it has been turned into
one input function
and then it's a one input function so we
can use composition
okay so let's actually see what this
looks like in practice
and this is why this understanding
functions as inputs and functions as
outputs
is such an important idea because we do
this a lot in functional programming
all right one input here one input there
so we've solved instead of having two
inputs we now have two functions each
with one input
so don't worry if you don't understand
this it definitely takes a while to get
your head around
if you're new to this kind of thing
right so every function can be converted
into a series of one input functions
this way
all right let's look at an example so
here we have our three input function
called replace and it's an object
oriented function so the
the third input is actually the object
that it's been called so this is a kind
of a three parameter function
and what we want to do is fix it up so
it turns into a one
parameter function now what we're going
to do here is have a new thing called
replace
and it is going to return a lambda okay
so we're going to pass in two parameters
these two parameters
but not the third parameter and the
output of this function
is going to be a lambda
not a value so we're returning a one
parameter function
so what we're doing here is this new one
parameter function can be chained
together
because it has one input and one output
so this is a this is the trick this is
the
way of kind of carrying the replace
function so we can use it
in our pipeline
so let's look at how we could do this in
c sharp so this is our
our curried version of replace
and it looks a bit more complicated but
we only need one of them
we don't have to um uh
have five helper functions we just need
one helper function now
and now in the pipeline we can call the
place
with different parameters over and over
so again this
returns a lambda which is can be used in
the pipeline
um and we're passing into the three
parameters
in the helper function and it returns a
lambda
and where does the input from the lambda
come from it comes from the pipeline
so this is uh using a carried function
in a pipeline and this is why curried
functions are so important
in functional programming let's look at
the f sharp version of this
now in f sharp you don't need help
function because everything is carried
automatically in f sharp so we can just
take this replace function and use it as
is without any helping
and so this is one of the nice things
about a language like f sharp is you
don't have to
do coin every single function is
automatically coded
that's very nice so again we're passing
in two of the three parameters
where is the other parameter coming from
it's coming from the pipeline
now what we're doing here is actually a
technique called
partial application which is a really
important technique
and it's very very closely related to
currying it's not the same as currying
but it's
it's very it's related to the idea of
curry so let me let me give you an
example
let's say we have two functions add and
multiply and they both have two
parameters
now in a pipeline what i can do
is just use one of the parameters
so if i say add two i'm passing in
one of the parameters where is the other
parameter coming from
it's coming from the pipeline so i am
i'm basically
passing in one of the two parameters and
similarly
when i'm passing one of the two
parameters here that is called partial
application
so uh i'm only partially providing
the parameters and the other parameters
have to come from somewhere else
and that's a really like i said this is
a very common technique and this only
works because the functions are
curried so currying means
making a bunch of one parameter
functions and the partial application
means
putting some of the parameters back but
not all of them
some of them but not all of them
so you'll see this this is a like i say
this is like super common technique in
functional programming
so if you look at our replace uh thing
that we did here
that's what we did we passed in two of
the three inputs and we sort of
baked it in to the uh function here
we're passing in two of the inputs
uh and the other input is coming from
the pipeline so this is partial
application
uh in our roman numeral example
so one of the great things about the
pipeline approach
is they are extensible so um
roman numerals um if i need to add a new
feature to the roman numerals i can just
add new things
i can say i can handle the eight the
nine case and the four case
uh i can just add new features without
touching the other features
so a pipeline oriented approach is is
really nice because i can
have confidence when i add new
functionality that i'm not breaking
anything else when i add new segments to
the pipeline
so this is another reason why my piping
model is a really nice way of
if you can try and get your code to work
in this pipeline model
there's a lot of other benefits as well
okay so
this is our challenge how do we compose
a function with one output
and two inputs and the answer was
currying and partial applications
so that's challenge has been solved good
right now let's look at another
challenge which is
a function with two outputs um so some
functions
have more than one output and and how do
we connect that to a function
with one input and i'll explain what i
mean by more than one output
shortly and the challenge is how do we
compose these kinds of things
uh and the answer is monads
um more specifically there's a function
called bind
uh for connecting these kinds of
functions together so i'm going to use
fizzbuzz as our example here um
here's first of all people aren't
familiar fizzbuzz you need to print fizz
if it's multiple divisible by three for
buzz if it's divisible by five and so on
and so forth otherwise you print the
original number
right now in f sharp uh we can have a
very simple implementation if it's
divisible by 15 print fizz buzz
otherwise print fizz otherwise print
buzz otherwise the original number
so that is the kind of standard
implementation that you might write if
you're an imperative
programmer and there's our little we
need a little helper function that does
that is divisible by
okay um we're not going to do that
because this is too easy uh we're
functional programmers we need to make
it more complicated
uh so i'm going to make a more
complicated version of fizzbuzz
i'm actually not going to make it just
for the sake of it i'm going to make it
to show you how you can do
composition out of something like this
this as it stands is not composable and
i want a composable version
a pipeline version of fsbus
so here's how you might do fizzbuzz as a
pipeline
you say well i want to handle the first
case and then i want to handle the
second case and the third case
and then finally you know the last case
so i want to do a pipeline
so let's see how we can implement a
pipeline for fizzbuzz
so when we handle a case in fizzbuzz um
there's two choices for the output we
could either say well it's unhandled
like you know two or something or seven
or whatever none of these are handled
or it is actually handled in which case
we get a string back
so we have two two choices for what this
function returns
it's something or something something or
something
that makes me think i need a choice type
so
from a railway or into point of view we
now have an input
and we have two kind of branches on our
on our
way track it's not just a one track
function now it has two possible outputs
and um this is different from what we've
seen before
so how can we model this in code
well i'm going to create a type which is
a choice it's either unhandled or
it's handled if it's unhandled we still
have the original integer
and if it is handled we now have a some
sort of string like fizz or buzz or
something
so we have a choice type this is why
they're very good
uh and i stole this from uh original
braithwaite
so there's a credit there um let's
see how we actually write the code to
handle it then
so we handle it if it is divisible by
the thing
then we say okay it's a we're going to
make the handle case happen it's at the
label the fins of the buzz
and if it isn't divisible by the thing
we're going to return the unhandled case
which is the original number so we
either return the label
or we return the original integer
so we've got two choices in our return
okay now notice that this is a three
parameter function
pay attention to that okay now let's
actually
test it out interactively now the nice
thing is these in these pieces are
independent
they're standalone so we can test them
on their own so we can handle
try handling 12 and it says that's good
that's fizz if we put 10 into that one
uh for three that is unhandled but if we
put ten into the five
one it is handled so we can test out the
little code each of these
components is independently testable
and notice that we've only got two
parameters here
and i said it was a three parameter
function where's the third parameter
coming from
it's coming from the pipeline okay so
this
two parameter function when we when we
put it when we bake in two parameter
functions
we now uh two parameters we now have a
one of these kind of switch
or points type railway track with one
input and two outputs
okay so if we try and do an
implementation like this
uh we say with this handle we're done if
it's unhandled
we try and handle three okay if it's
handled we're done
it's unhandled let's try handle five if
that's handled we're done
otherwise we do the last thing this is a
really really ugly implementation
um but you often see this kind of thing
when you have nested
uh when you have kind of different kinds
of results that you can return
so let's let's try and get rid of this
ugly codes
um there's actually a pattern here it's
not i don't know if it's obvious but
here's the pattern
every time it's unhandled we do
something with the unhandled value
but we you know if it's a handle we're
done if it's unhandled we do something
if it's handled we're done if it's
unhandled we do something
so that's the pattern if it's handled
we're done
if it's unhandled we're going to do
something so let's turn this into a
helper function
um if you if you think of it going to
the railway oriented example it's like
if it's unhandled we call the next
function
but if it's handled we bypass it that's
what's basically going on from a railway
point of view
uh that's what's that's how we can think
about it so let's write a little helper
function
that's going to do this for us so if
unhandled do
i'm going to call it so if we're handled
we leave it as handled
if it's unhandled we're going to do
something now what are we going to do
i don't know it depends so i'm going to
just say some arbitrary function
f well where does this function f come
from it comes from a parameter so we're
going to pass in a function parameter
that controls how this function works
and that was exactly what i was talking
about at the beginning of the talk
so and i'm going to call it f because i
have no idea what this function is i
can't think of a better name
than f right so if we have this new
helper function we can write unhandled
do
we can change our logic and we say well
handle 15 if it's still unhandled
handle three if it's still unhandled
handle five and if it's still unhandled
do the last step
so each of these little steps is one of
these branching railway things
and we can chain them together now
using this if unhandled do the last step
brings the two tracks together and
basically says if it's handled that's
the string and if it's unhandled
we just turn the integer into a string
so it converts both sides into a string
and this is composable unlike the
original version
because we can handle new things we just
stick them in the pipeline
and we're not touching any existing code
so this is a much more
safe version of fizzbuzz than the
original version we're guaranteed that
we add new features we're not going to
break anything
now obviously fizzbuzz is a very silly
example but you can think of a more
complicated thing
where turning it into a composable thing
like this makes it
much more extensible and much easier to
understand what's going on
now let's look at another example which
is chaining tasks
often you have tasks you know when the
task completes you do something else
but when the task doesn't complete you
skip it
and you know promises futures whatever
you want to call them
the same idea you need to chain things
these things together
now if you look at the kind of code that
you often see you start a task and when
the task is finished
do something else when the task is
finished do something else and when the
task is finished do something else
or promises or whatever this is really
ugly um
however we can use the same pattern
when it's finished do something when
it's finished do something when it's
finished do something
and let's write a little helper function
for that
when it's finished do something now what
is it going to do
i'm going to pass in a function
parameter i don't know exactly what it's
going to do so that i'm going to pass
any function parameters that's going to
do it for me because that's parametrized
and once we have a helper function like
this
we can rewrite the code to be much more
linear
much more as in a straight line and so
this is
again this is a really useful approach
for tasks and you'll see this i think in
javascript there's something called
and then which is exactly the same thing
as when finished do
and this brings us to monads
so why monads well
what we want to do is a general solution
or a general
way of thinking about handling functions
like this and
there's a fun there's a way of thinking
called bind a bind is sort of the
generic name
for uh the function that composes these
things together
so if we go back to the railway analogy
and we want to connect these things
together
um how do we compose these well we
compose them into a two-track model so
that's before
and that's afterwards and i call this
the two-track model otherwise known as
railway oriented programming
and i have a talk on this one too so
that's the idea if we have a two-track
model
we can connect these things together but
here's the problem
um composing one track functions is easy
we connect the inputs to the outputs
composing two track functions is also
easy we just connect
you know the corresponding inputs and
outputs but we don't have that we have
one input and two outputs and they can't
compose
so what we have here is a function like
this that is not composable
however if we had a function like this a
two track function
this is composable we can connect these
ones together so now our problem is how
do we
go from the four case to the after case
how do we transform
the top function into a function that
looks like the bottom function
and now this is where bind comes in so
bind
is the name for a generic kind of
adapter block
that solves this problem and if you're
using the model railway approach
you often see this kind of thing there's
a there's a two-track system and there's
a slot on the top
where you fit your model railway so we
have a slot for function
we pass in our our switches or points
function
we put it in the slot and it comes out
as a two-track function
so that's what i call a function
transformer a function comes in
and it comes out as a different shape
and the new shape is
is a much better shape much more usable
shape because we can compose
these shapes together so the
implementation is really easy
um it's a lot more complicated to
explain it than it is to write the codes
so if we use the the fizzbuzz example
you know it comes in on a two-track if
it's unhandled
we do the next function in the in the
track
and that's fine and if it was handled
already we just don't do anything we
just returned
the original value so that says bind for
the fizzbuzz now if you notice carefully
this is exactly the same as the if
unhandled do function
it's exactly the same design so bind and
if one handle do
the same thing so bind often has many
many different names for yourself is
often
called flat map sometimes it's called
and then
and in c sharp it's select many um
there's lots of different names for this
thing but it's the same concept it's a
way of chaining
functions together like this so in
functional programming
terminology we have something called the
monads and the monad is actually
not as complicated as it might sound
it's really just a data type
and a bind function and some other stuff
so a data type
like fizzbuzz results where it's handled
unhandled or a task
uh and the bind function in our case it
was if unhandled do
or for the task it was it when finished
do
you know so it's a data type and an
associated function it's a combination
of those two things
that's what a monad is and sometimes
you'll hear the word magnetic
function and a magnetic function is one
of these switch
points functions and we use bind to
compose them so
in our case in this fizzbuzz case it was
the handle function it was one of these
switches with one input and and two
outputs so that's what a magnetic
function is
right so this is our challenge how do we
have two outputs
and one input and we solve that with
monads
and this is why functional programmers
go on and on about monads all the time
because this is a very common situation
and monads is the way of chaining things
together
where they are the wrong shape and
monads turn them into the right shape
where they can be composed so that's
what monas are useful for
right now just to finish up i'm going to
talk about building a web service
using another kind of composition called
lightly composition
if we take our if we think about our two
little bits of railway track like this
which are you know points functions if
we combine them
like this it's really obvious how to
combine them and then you kind of
pretend the middle isn't there
it actually has the same shape as the
original function
right it actually is one of these kinds
of functions again
right so what we're saying here is a way
of composing them
so that you combine two of these and you
make another one which is the same
shape now that's a very important part
because if it's some if it's the same
kind of thing you can keep adding and
adding just like lego
so if you if you combine two things and
you make something which is the same
kind of thing
that's a very powerful concept uh and
it's a it's a great and very important
part of composition
and you can build bigger things and
smaller things because no matter what
you do you always end up something with
the same shape
right so let's apply this approach to
building
a web server or web service or whether
whatever
so we're going to have something called
the http handler
and also known as a web part okay
so the input is an http context
and this contains everything about the
service has the request it also has the
partially built response the cookies
everything you need to make a decision
about what to do
and then what comes out is an
asynchronous http context
option and it's optional because if you
can handle it
you're going to return something um and
if you can't handle it
it's optional you're going to turn
nothing so it's either something or
nothing
and that's what optional means so it's
either going to be success or failure
and the whole thing is an asynchronous
thing because you might be hitting
databases or
hitting a network who knows how long
it's going to take so it's asynchronous
right so this is the components that
we're going to build our web framework
from
and uh if you want to know more about
the f-sharp version search for f-sharp
giraffe and you can see this web
framework there
so this composition actually has a
symbol
with a angle bracket equal angle
brackets called the kleisler composition
symbol
and we can combine two things to make
another thing of the same type so that's
what we're going to do just like lego
it's another http handler you can keep
adding and adding and adding
right so let's look at some examples
here's something called
path and what that does is just check
whether the input path
is matches so this matches
hello um and if it does match the path
it returns success and if it doesn't
match the path it's a failure
that's all it does it's one little
component it's a building block
um here is another one called okay and
all it does is return 200.
okay so it's another building block now
we can combine these two building blocks
with the clysley composition right
first part we'll check the request path
the second part will set the response
so we have these two little building
blocks we combine them and
now we have a slightly bigger uh
component
and this component will check the path
and then return okay
right now another component another tool
is the choose
and with choose we pass in a bunch of
these things
and what it does is it tries the first
one and if that doesn't work it tries
the second one if it doesn't work it
tries the third one
and if that doesn't work the whole thing
is a failure so what it does
is it combines these things and it also
returns something of the same shape
right either one of them works you get
success or none of them work in which
case you get failure
so that is also the same kind of shape
and we can build that into something so
for example
we could have hello returns okay
and goodbye also returns okay and that
something else doesn't work at all
so we can now pick the first path that
succeeds
so now we've got our our our handlers
here
for the path handling and each for each
path handling we can have a little
web component that handles that
particular path in this case we're just
returning
hello goodbye but obviously it could be
a lot more complicated than that
now here's another one called get and
this returns successful
if the request is a get and if it's not
a get it doesn't
so we can build a get component here so
now this
only works if it's a get and the path is
hello then we're going to do
the hello thing and if the if it's a get
and the path is goodbye it's going to do
a thing
and if it's getting it's something else
it's going to return nothing
so complete web app looks something like
this if it's a get do one of these two
things
otherwise fail if it's a post do one of
these two things
otherwise fail and the entire
application
is just choosing between the get and the
post so this is our
our router written in a composable
functional way using clysley composition
and the entire web location just looks
like this start the web server with this
with this with this component
so you can see this is building bigger
things from smaller things
um using composition just like we did
for everything else
and what's nice about this approach is
that each of these individual handlers
are composable and they're testable
they're reasonable i could test the path
bit on its own i could test just the
hello the routing part on its own i can
test the post
part on its own i can test each piece on
its own and then when i combine them
i have high confidence that they will
work together i don't have to like
be forced to test the entire application
in one go
so it's a very nice technique the the
lego analogy is very very
suitable here so no classes by the way
there were no classes there's no
factories there's no proxies manager
classes all that stuff is just
pure functions combined together with
composition
right now when you take the entire web
request like this again
i said it was a function right so
obviously there's branching and stuff
going on
but there's no classes no inheritance
and it's a one directional
data flow and that's so nice for
being able to debug things that's the
power of composition
so let's just quickly review and then
i'll i'll finish up um
so i talked about the philosophy of
composition uh i talked about
using connectable reusable parts uh
building bigger things from smaller
things that's the that's the fundamental
idea and we saw this with lego
we saw with train tracks and now we saw
it with functions as well
and then the functional principles you
have composable functions
and you have composable types so these
things are designed to be standalone
they're not attached to a class
they're not tangled up with anything
else there's no
they're no they're not there's no
strings attached they are completely
reusable standalone things and this is a
very powerful
concept you design your function you
assume that other people are going to be
reusing your functions to design them
that way um
we looked at various compositional
techniques we looked at piping
we looked at currying and partial
application
we looked at composition using bind
which is the monad
scary bone adword and we looked at
closing composition
and all these things are different ways
of solving different composition
problems so almost everything you do in
functional programming
all things like monas and stuff they're
all techniques to solve composition it's
like we want to compose things
here's a little way of doing it we use
monad so here's another way we use
carrying well here's another way
you know so all the techniques you hear
about in functional programming are
really to do with getting composition to
work
so hopefully this is a very quick whiz
through
everything i don't expect you to
understand all this stuff obviously in
an hour however hopefully it's been a
little bit demystified
and so if you're like homer at least
you're not scared by it
um you can see that there's a you know
it's it is understandable it's not
it's not magic it's not mysterious it's
not mathematical at all
so i would encourage you to go you know
and and do more research on this
if you think this is an interesting way
of doing programming
so hopefully it's not so scary um that
was if
if you come away less scared by moan ads
then this talk is a success
so why bother with all this stuff like
the fizz buzz
was that was actually worth it and i
think yes there's a lot of benefits to
composition first of all everything's
reusable
everything's testable everything's more
understandable because the data flows in
one direction
everything's more maintainable because
everything's explicit
and everything's kind of extendable
because you can add new parts there's
lots and lots of benefits to this kind
of
compositional way this pipeline way of
doing things
and the final benefit i think this is a
different way of thinking it's good for
you
to learn new ways of doing things rather
than just being stuck in the rut and
doing things you're familiar with
try getting out of your butt and
learning a new way of thinking about
building programs
so i'm going to put the slides and video
up there on my website slash composition
uh feel free to contact me on twitter uh
this is my book again i have to have to
promote my book of course and then
thank you very much for coming i will be
taking questions in the
slack channel and uh or like i say or
contact me on twitter
thanks i hope you found this useful i
will see you later